the Vanity Fair cover that you did when
you were naked and you were pregnant I
think with your second daughter yeah
we're so iconic
Annie Leibovitz shot that cover yes she
came down to Paducah Kentucky when I was
pregnant with my first daughter and we
did nude photos for us right so at the
end you just hired Annie Leibovitz she
just came down and she's a friend yeah
she she did our wedding she basically
chronicled the whole growth of our
family so when you were pregnant you
trusted it because you weren't gonna be
on the cover of a magazine yeah I mean
at one point at very end of the shoot we
were doing it and I said why wouldn't it
be amazing if they used this for the
cover and then a week later they called
and asked and you know I was just trying
to do the shoot reflective of how I felt
it was amazing how I felt as you know
which was you know women were only in
Peter Pan collars right it's like
celebrating you could celebrate finding
out that you're pregnant and you could
celebrate once you have the child but in
the in-between it was like culturally we
have to pretend we've never had sex that
we you know that it's like this
Immaculate Conception
well pregnancy was like you hide your
body now all of a sudden was being
celebrated it was a revolutionary thing
to actually do it it's almost like it
liberated everyone every woman was doing
a pregnancy shoot to card - did the
Kardashians Kari I love it I would you
know I it's incredibly complimentary but
I like that we have the freedom to
express that and you point out in the
book they the Vanity Fair people had it
when they shipped the the magazines out
to their subscribers they had to cover
them on the newsstand they had to cover
them so that people wouldn't see your
body huh [ __ ] bizarre no no I I
couldn't believe how crazy the response
was as if it was pornographic